what your competition does is it helps
reveal to you your weaknesses
competition is good it keeps you awake
at night it makes you think you get the
benefit of hearing what everybody else
has to think before you render your
opinion it's like a hammer you can use
it broadly or narrowly you can build a
table you can build a house it's the
same tool now I said before that the
only true competitor in and in an
infinite game is yourself this is true
what your competition does is it helps
reveal to you your weaknesses admire the
others in your organization not to beat
them there's no such thing not to be
number one there's no such thing but if
somebody else is better than you at
something that means you have to go work
harder yourself it's like running in a
race if you're driven to be number one
if you're driven to make the most money
if you're driven to show up in some
arbitrary ranking that you didn't even
have a say in that's like tripping the
the next runner you will win the race
but you're still a slow runner rather
fall behind this year and then you work
and work and work because ultimately the
goal is not to be number one this year
the goal is to create an organization
that will outlast every single one of
you this is about building strong
foundations this is about looking long
term and the short term money is simply
fuel to to to make the car go we don't
own cars to buy more fuel we own cars to
go somewhere it's the same thing in an
organization your organization exists to
advance something the money is simply
there to make a go and I fear that what
has happened in the university system is
similar to what I'm seeing in business
it's similar to what I'm seeing in
politics it's similar to what I'm seeing
in Hospice
which is an over the sense of excessive
pressure to bring money in at the
expense of something else there's an
excessive amount of short-termism and
massive amounts of rationalizing this is
just the game we just have to do it if
we don't somebody else will the
obsession with getting grants meaning
you're hiring people who are more likely
to help you get a grant even though
they're teaching things that we don't
necessarily even need or want
that's called short-termism
unfortunately I can't tell you the last
piece because I've run out of time
you're going to be made this with Gordon
Ramsay
you feel about that no he is great
brilliant I'm another you know I've
always got on with him I've I don't see
him very often he's in the states a lot
and you know but when I do see him we
have a good laugh and and you know we
cook in very different ways we have very
different customers and we have very
different audiences so I think it's
brilliant if anything is gonna bring
more people here which is good for me
really we've got quite a lot of good
operators within a square 400 million
and yeah now I've been doing the grew up
in the business it's a competition it's
good it keeps you awake at night it
makes you think that's a good thing and
also there's plenty of room for everyone
you know whether it's great burgers down
there or you know Italian door pizzas or
there's there's quite a lot going on
it's been a big thing for me I grew up
in a family business so you know when
your brother down the road had equipment
that went pear-shaped you lend him yours
you know I've never really understood
the very London attitude towards chefs
and the bitterness and the hatred and
for Adam he done even he don't even
recognize it because it's not like that
holidays there it's an attorney so you
know that's why if Gordon comes next to
all Happy Days god bless him you know
and if his guys need anything I'm here
and hopefully vice versa if they run out
of ice I can go and get some cubes you
know you know I personally started this
rivalry from a young age witnessing and
worshipping Serena and Venus practicing
at this tennis academy in Florida as a
13 year old girl with hundreds of kids
next to me and she was already a Grand
Slam champion with her sister and I you
know the single thought that I had was I
wanted to beat her in a few years later
I find myself it was really as if
someone took me and put me into a
television screen of facing Serena
Williams in a final and I'm someone that
honestly did not belong there I mean I
had nothing I was not ready I was not as
tall as I as I gotten to be I was far
from being as strong or physically
capable of competing in two weeks but
somehow I was there and I was facing her
and and she was intimidate
she was strong her presence was there
her confidence the confidence that she's
played with for so many years and you
know so much of is talked about and I
know that a lot of the headlines a lot
of the experts that were chosen from the
book has been about Sarina and
rightfully so because so much of it has
been talked for years on end but deep
down there's an incredible amount of
respect that I have for her and and one
of the things I speak about in the book
it's almost like we should be friends
because we understand what it's like
every single day and not just by playing
tennis not forehands and backhands but
we know everything that goes with the
sport the pressures the responsibilities
the sponsors the professionalism the
press conference everything that we face
it's almost like we have so many like
common factors and yet we we have to be
rivals in order to beat each other you
know we must have that drive against
each other and having her across the net
only makes you a better player because
the her level is on another planet
competition is a good thing if you are
incompetent and you're in competition
you will feel stressed
[Applause]
if you want to be in a competitive
situation the thing is you have to work
on your competence right now the problem
is you're tweaking your desire you're
not tweaking your competence this is
what has to happen that we must teach
children to tweak their competence not
their desire we are calling this
ambition we calling this goal oriented
Ness ambition means what you tweaked up
your desire you will suffer invariably
if you tweak up your competence you will
see wherever you go you are doing better
than what people expect you to so
naturally
things will go well for you competition
is not the bad thing lack of competence
is the bad thing so instead of
competence we have big desires
if you focus enough on enhancing your
competence you will see there is such
joy in breaking limitations every day
and becoming something better you don't
care a damn how somebody else is doing
some people see the thing that they want
and some people see the thing that
prevents them from getting the thing
that they want it's as if an entire
generation is standing at the foot of a
mountain they know exactly what they
want they can see the summit what they
can't see is the male